[Applause]
hello hey hi neighbor neighbor Lu we had
never had a conversation except the
server's never had a conversation we've
never met and we live in the same town
some town that is no Valley of the dolls
exactly so I want to know I want to know
about you in a sense so we had an email
exchange and and we we started playing
with the polarity of what we do and how
we do it and came up with these
opposites which is the monk and the
connector oxytocin and dopamine yeah
yeah and you are so so involved and have
been involved at the robot and I listen
to your commencement speech you did at
Berkeley last May I guess it was May
yeah and your your you were right there
at that crest you know from being
injured to the web and then the webbie's
and and really just immersing yourself
into this connectivity and your movie
that you work in right now is called
connections and so first question is
what did you think of Malcolm Gladwell
sorry take that in the air today
well um Malcolm Gladwell's article that
basically was taking down Twitter as a
means of social revolution I don't think
he's totally right but I think his
skepticism is right and I think we are
at the beginning of seeing the potential
of so many people online with these
tools and I'm very excited about Twitter
right now now do I believe that it was
you could save the Iran revolution no
and I I think that people are may be
overstating what it's doing exactly
right now but I think we're at the
beginning of this huge moment where
you're able to have people cross
pollinating ideas from all over the
world like what's not exciting about
that and so when you get
from billions of people that have a
common interest and they're sharing ways
to solve problems that were in work just
at the beginning of this moment that's
incredibly exciting so whether he wants
to shoot it down
and I love Malcolm Gladwell's writing
and his ideas and he's a provocateur
he's a cultural provocateur anything
poking holes and you know things which i
think is great and we need people like
him to do that but I am very hopeful at
the potential of what it can bring I
mean I was listening is I want to talk
to you but a little bit of what you're
optimistic about in a second but I kind
of feel like Twitter and checking
texting and email you know they've just
come out with a study that you get a
little you get a little hit of oxytocin
well dopamine is when you seek
information on Google but oxytocin is
when you have a connection on one on one
connection so I love this idea that
everyone's getting these hits of
oxytocin because oxytocin makes you less
fearful more empathetic more generous so
the the thought as addicted as we're all
becoming and I'm completely struggling
with that addiction and being present
and all the things we're all struggling
with but I am excited about the idea of
this worldwide global oxytocin that's
happening and beginning to happen so you
think that's happening I think what like
I said I think we're at the beginning of
that I mean I like the tea party people
are on the web too you know I know they
are I've but I do not believe they will
prevail I mean I think that's a
reactionary I think there's more listen
any tool can be used for positive you
know any tool can be it's a neutral
medium and it's the human energy and
spirit and creativity that's going to
channel what that technology is used for
and I am ultimately an optimist about
the human spirit I mean I know the were
the most compassionate and violent of
all the species which is the great
paradox of humans but I'm ultimately an
optimist and in speaking of optimist can
we go because I heard I
I love your work and I've followed it
and it's so exciting to finally be
meeting you in person
weirdly here but um what are you
optimistic about I mean the whole
Blessed unrest and you you named the
zeitgeist you named this this happening
and why is there earth and doesn't that
give you hope that that what gives you
hope well I like I said I'm really
looked at that hope and I actually try
to put hope aside because I feel like
hope is basically fed by fear and hope
so well it's just suggesting is is there
a way to be in the world where it's not
about hope it's about compassion it's
about caring it's about love it's about
community it's about family it's about
you know that the the revelation of the
realization that Kathryn had which is
really none of us or anybody really
we're all nobodies and there's a great
relief in that and that our journey here
our path here is actually to find ways
to serve to become and so that to me is
more interesting than then this or the
artifice of hope you know which depends
on a projection of days maybe maybe that
word actually as you're saying and I
because I mean one thing I found with
getting older or you know I just turned
40 so you know I just lost my father
which was very hard and but it brought
me so much closer to people hmm
all the people that had lost their
father or lost a parent or lost somebody
close to them and what I'm finding is
I'm getting older and I think the web
and Twitter and Facebook not
superficially I think it's letting you
find those commonalities that common
human experience about being ordinary
living and dying having children having
the same fears and in hopes that it's in
our commonality that I think these tools
and not just these tools because
obviously being present is incredibly
important and turn unplugging what I
find me
interesting right now and and what I
love to see is that I see the world
moving closer and closer to what I call
a teachable moment and or teachable
moments and because I mean there's a
great deal of you know Sturman dwelling
and angst about you know 2008-2009 and
you know this collapse of asset values
and you know people thought what they
had you know it doesn't exist and to me
when you begin to realize that what you
thought was wasn't it's actually very
helpful because it's see it's it's great
it's like the barns burned down now I
can see the moon yeah exactly exactly
but the barn did exist in this case our
money in United States did not exist
that was just a village of an economy
that we all lived in and we still do and
you go to poo bottle with somebody and
see the deficit you know counter going
on you know and you know what one thing
that I love that you said was that you
believe I'm curious if you still believe
this that business which created so many
of these problems has this he said this
restless creative energy that you think
will actually solve well business will
so will civil society so well religion
so we'll school children's or mothers I
mean it's it's all that's altogether
just that business at that time is so
denigrated as a agent of social change
or and I thought that denigration wasn't
by helpful and furthermore it wasn't
very descriptive either because what
happens is we see the you know the the
players and the actors who are not good
actors in business and they're they've
been here since the converse existed but
and they obscure the you know who's
trying to make a difference and who's
trying to make a difference often time
isn't who gets the publicity gets the
news gets a I've been really excited
about be corporation because yeah yes
just that they're you know certifying
corporations that incorporate
interdependence and sustainability into
their bylaws and yeah I mean I that's a
very exciting
but one of the things I see right now
and I've mentioned this before is that I
the what I think the progressive
movement has to Seattle f2 what you want
to call it that is that the delusions on
the right are pretty well masked by the
delusions on the left about energy and
climate and everybody's you know just as
every religion has a extremist I mean in
in the the the thing I see right now is
that as the the left and in a sense it
seems to understand the problem but to
me that the solutions that are being put
forth are sort of delusive and the right
seems I think there isn't a problem you
know and so it's a funny kind of
interplay and dynamic between the two
which isn't going to really work out an
interesting way in the next 10 20 years
because in between oh that is reality
you know which is resource flow and
economics and and who's got what when
where and so that's going to play out in
everyone's life time here and there's
gonna be a very very radical shift in
power and locus of what I call real
power in a sense of really who's got the
brains and intelligence to really see
ahead and plan for it and who does and
we don't right now in the United States
we're trying to be honey apple well we
you were just talking about and you
talked talked before you know about
natural capital and what do you think
about idea capital I mean what are your
thoughts you said you're not on any
networks was I was just it was lopsided
too too much in and not enough hours so
did you just make a conscious to say I
just got on Facebook I got everything
yeah how long ago oh my god just
completely outside looking at and you
probably you think I'm not outside well
no no no no no no no no she hot outside
the venmo Valley you're always outside
no but you're outside of because
Twitter's kind of blown up in the two
years that you've been off so what do
you think of it I have no idea I'm just
so happy not to be on it I mean I know
when I did speeches people say oh I got
a tweet you know you know it's like
while you're talking and so forth oh
there was good but for me I mean I have
as many friends as I can possibly serve
I know the words are weird I mean
Renne the fanpage they're weird words
because they they mean one thing and
they're very different in these kind of
social graphs that's it is there are
misnomers which I think actually comes
is the basis for so much critique is you
have thousands of friends and they're
not you know I you I'm not for taking it
I'm just saying is I enjoy but I think
the names are kind of part of where the
mantle is up here and it's really this
third space that needs new words yeah
I'm just saying I enjoy my life better
that's all and I compared to a bee went
to a went back to be a better and B you
have a cell phone that you use I do have
a cell phone I don't use it for calling
now there's traffic on the bridge while
I was driving here are you on the web a
lot I mean like tell me a typical day in
in Paul's like what what you get up and
do you start to check in on do you go
with you what's on your nightstand books
no of course but which books right now
lives a lot there's a lot of books on
Buddhism there's a lot of books I'm
learning trying to learn Tibetan cuz I'm
gonna know what prayers actually mean
that I'm saying there's the book radical
by which is really interesting this by
this Christian ministers 26 year old 26
years old in Louisiana and he's written
a book that's just talk about a takedown
takedown of
yeah other than megachurches and
everything and said look at read read
the bottle again you know and Jesus gave
everything away Jesus said you know do
not accumulate Jesus said serve you know
and still believe in God no and well
it's not a belief system you know God's
not a belief system and and so what's so
interesting about it though is just
somebody who's really looking at
Christianity and this rise of you know
Christian materialism you know this yeah
and he just it's not that I want to join
his church it's just that I feel like
it's a really example of some really
interesting new kind of literature where
people just speaking truth very
powerfully and as Katherine was saying
you know it's hard to do it in the media
itself but you could still do it in
books yeah no I mean I definitely I mean
I you know the whole I thought her point
was great of just that the attention
issue and going in deep on books and I
know my the way my mind has work is
definitely changed in the last five
years and it concerns me for sure and I
think but I think the the system's like
what you named with you know what you're
doing with wise are worth and that I'm
not that well there was a community we
community started it but I guess the the
kind of nature of organizations networks
people with common interests and we're
seeing such a rise of kind of thinking
about systems and interdisciplinary and
you know I love it yo Wilson said the
future of science is a science of
systems and looking at the kind of
systems not just biologically but
socially in humans I mean does that
resonate with you because I know you
don't work with biomimicry and thinking
of kind of human systems common
interests and do you ever think about it
that way uh hopefully all the time I
mean I think one of the things that
impressed me once when I was talking to
a scientist in Sweden and he he really
pointed out that we are born systems
thinkers and it takes you know 16 years
and about four or five hundred thousand
dollars to get it out of us you know and
then we try to relearn it and and the
example of systems thinking is really
how we learn language because when we
are pre lingual so to speak we are
hearing an unbroken series of sounds you
know listen to our parents talk or
brothers or sisters and siblings and but
actually most of what we're hearing is
not hello my name is you know Paul I
mean that's not what babies hear they
hear
the stream of language and they watch
facial expressions they see actions and
so forth
and out of that to begin to parse and
out of that they start to create you
know the understanding of language
universally everywhere in the world
always and so this sort of ability to
see things as systems is innate you know
and systems really is sort of a code
word for the one truth that there is it
that is its oneness which is everything
is connected nothing is disconnected and
yeah so you know I mean when you think
of when we really do think
systematically is when we do say a
launch in space I mean except we've got
the o-rings wrong ones but when we think
that way and they're kind of NASA type
level that is systems thinking about you
know and when you think of LA then you
think that's not systems thinking
because that's why we can put an
electric car on the moon but not in LA
and that's really the difference is
really that ability to think in terms of
the whole yeah my new films all about
kind of systems thinking and
connectedness but all the different ways
of it but I love that what you just said
about you're born that way I think
that's yeah yeah yeah yeah and so it's
something that I'm not sure how you can
you can bring it back and I think the
comments earlier to about you know about
scenarios is very apt Ritz's you're
seeing I think you know I don't know you
know whether the Hindus are right about
Kali Yuga but it feels like I call it
yoga in the sense that you know time is
speeding up times accelerating that was
the prediction of this you know epic
sort of like the ice skater you know who
brings their arms in you know when
they're spinning and then a student
passing faster and faster and faster and
it's the same person but the dynamics
have changed and it seems to me that
that acceleration of time is is
occurring much abetted by obviously the
digital world which has sped up
everything and made us impatient for the
things that we would wait a week for
before and in that speeding up I think
it's more and more difficult for people
to step back and that's why I asked
Catherine about the sabbatical because
in a sense the retreat the silence the
monastic is a way of stepping back
and trying to get that thing that
Stewart was talking about when he's
going with the sign and you know in San
Francisco why haven't we seen a picture
of the whole earth
you know why haven't we seen why haven't
we seen ourselves that Buddhist says you
know when you look at a body of water
and the wind is blowing across it and
you see all the reflections and it's not
until the wind on the water that you see
inside and I think about I mean my
husband and I try to do technology
shabbat s-- on saturdays we're offline
and it's really hard but one day a week
you know it yeah is it that hard is very
hard' what's part is hard I mean when we
go out of town um it's great because we
really do go offline and we take a lot
of road trips and and we have a blast
but for one day a week that
disconnection moment is very difficult
do you feel withdrawal yeah it's like I
think that's the dough I mean that's
where the kind of hormonal dopamine
oxytocin I think we are literally
addicted and I do feel like I twitch
well it's lovely talking - I'm good -
right outstanding thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you